[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 24 mars
quatre-vingt mille véhicules par jour
circulent sur la nationale 10 à hauteur
de trappes ou réduire les nuisances
liées au trafic mais aussi relient les
différents quartiers
la première étape du chantier
d'enfouissement de la n10 vient de
démarrer
nous ferons notamment le point avec
notre invité michelle perell de la
direction des routes d'île de france une
fréquentation en chute libre le château
de versailles a besoin d' aide le
département des yvelines va le soutenir
financièrement
15 millions d'euros sur trois ans et
puis au cours de ce journal rencontre
avec stéphanie gastaldo qui vient de
créer son entreprise de cosmétiques
nommé li na est situé à saint germain en
laye la marque met en avant des produits
naturels et se veut proche des femmes et
aussi des restaurateurs qui cuisine en
ehpad à sartrouville pour débuter
d'abord cette information sport la
saison de football amateur pour les
championnats départementaux et régionaux
et arrêter définitivement la fédération
française de football a annoncé sa
décision cet après midi elle fait suite
à la mise en place d'un nouveau
confinement dans le pays pour 16
départements dont ceux de l'île de
france et avec une épidémie deux
cohabitent 2,9 qui ne faiblit pas cette
décision entraîne une saison blanche
pour ces compétitions amateurs pas de
monter ni de descente pour les clubs
engagés dans ces championnats en ce qui
concerne la nationale 2 et la d2
féminine suspendu pour le moment la
décision sera prise ultérieurement
[Musique]
comme je vous le disais en titre la
nationale 10 qui à terme sera enfoui
continue sa mue après un début de
chantier en juillet 2018
plus de 80 mille véhicules l'empruntent
chaque jour des équipes travaillent
actuellement au niveau du pont cache un
os tout proche de la mairie de trappes
juste avant d'accueillir notre invité à
ce sujet ont fait le point avec mélanie
poké justin brasier et patrick jacques
de dixmude le pont cachard ne sera
bientôt plus dans le paysage depuis le
1er mars le chantier a débuté tout
proche de la mairie de trappe avant la
mise en place d'une dalle et
l'enfouissement de la nationale 10 les
ouvriers préparent un pont provisoire
pour garantir en fait la circulation sur
la rd 36 en obligé donc de réaliser un
ouvrage provisoire donc à pont
provisoire pour garantir la circulation
donc durant les travaux en fait de la
déviation de la rn 10 donc ces travaux
de la déviation de la rn 10 en fait qui
vont durer donc à peu près deux ans et
demi donc on est obligé de garantir la
circulation sur la rd 36 que ce soit
pour les piétons que pour les usagers
et donc ce compromis l'on en fait sur un
contre effectivement donc jusqu'à l'été
et donc sera mis en circulation d'ici là
le pont cachin sera démoli dans le
courant de l'été le chantier de la
nationale discours sur toute la commune
de trappes deux autres dalle permettront
de rejoindre le nord et le sud de la
ville au niveau du pavillon bleu et de
la station service une entrée une
traversée principale sur un plateau de
près de 3000 mètres car on sait
l'immense juste sous la mairie trappe
devant la mairie tap
donc on va aménager tout une place qui
va devenir une vraie agora de la ville
de trappes on pourra se retrouver pour
faire la fête pour le marché du dimanche
matin
une concertation ligne va être lancée
dans les mois qui viennent auprès des
habitants les deux autres aménagements
concerneront les traversées piétonnes et
un vélo et pour continuer de parler de
ce chantier de la nationale 10 avec nous
en visioconférence nous accueillons
michelle perell bonsoir vous êtes le
responsable de la maîtrise d'oeuvre de
ce chantier pour la direction des routes
d'île de france
la dirif alors pour rappel ce projet
d'enfouissement de la n10 remonte à 1999
il consiste à dénivelé l' axe routier
sur une longueur de près de 800 mètres
jusqu'à sept mètres de profondeur
hauteur de l'hôtel de ville de trappes
des travaux préparatoires ont été lancés
en 2018 et ont duré environ deux ans on
l'a entendu dans le reportage à
l'instant le chantier a enfin démarré et
enfin pu réellement démarré et durera
entre six et sept ans du coup quelles
sont justement les prochaines étapes à
venir
ce que ce soit dans les prochaines
années ou même récemment dans ce
chantier michelle perell alors ce que
nous avons lancé très récemment c'est
donc la construction d'un pont
provisoire pour remplacer pour marcel
cachin qui supportent à la rd36 cet
ouvrage prise orale nous permettent de
creuser la rn et donc de démolir le pont
actuel qui rend qui empêcherait ces
travaux là dans un deuxième temps donc
ces travaux on nous conduire jusqu'à
jusqu'à cet été et dans un deuxième
temps on va attaquer des travaux de
réaménagement du carrefour entre la
nationale 10 et la rd 912 donc celles au
nord
l'entrée de trappes dans les yvelines
par le nord on va réaménager ce
carrefour donc en giratoire à feu avec
un passage souterrain donc là c'est une
phase de travaux qui durera environ deux
ans et qui va apporter des bénéfices en
termes de de fluidification de la
circulation dans le secteur
ensuite viendra vraiment de la plus
grosse base de travaux qui est vraiment
le creusement de la rn10 qui va
permettre de là
de la cale et 7 mètres en dessous de son
niveau actuel est de construire par
dessus trois dalles et enfin ce chantier
se terminera avec le réaménagement du
carrefour entre la nationale 10 est là
et la départementale rd 23 aux suites de
tram donc un chantier je le rappelle
entre six et sept ans en tout cas pour
les six prochaines années
l'objectif du coût de ce chantier et de
ce projet c'est de désenclaver les
quartiers nord notamment de trappes
mais c'est aussi de réduire le réduire
par dont les nuisances du trafic routier
nuisances classés en catégorie sonore
une c'est la plus haute et je rappelle
donc cesser 88 véhicules environ un jour
qui empruntent cet axe qui font cette
nuisance
ce chantier j'imagine qu'il aura un
impact sur la circulation dans les
prochains mois mais aussi dans les
prochaines années
et justement qu'elle sera cet impact
alors vous le savez la rn 10 est un axe
particulièrement congestionné le matin
le soir très régulièrement notre
engagement sur ce chantier c'est de ne
pas aggraver ces conditions de
circulation qui sont déjà compliquée et
concrètement ça veut dire que pendant
tout le chantier pendant les six ans on
s'efforcera de maintenir à tout moment
la circulation à deux fois deux voies
sur la sur la nationale donc ça va
impliquer la création de chaussée
produisant puisque quand à certains
moments on va creuser en lieu et place
de national actuel il va falloir créer
une chaussée à côté chaussée provisoire
pour qu'à tout moment il y ait deux fois
deux voies de circulation sur cet axe
est con qu'on gère ainsi la circulation
comment de la même façon dont on
reconnaît actuellement
et ceci est particulièrement important
durant la période événementiel des jeux
olympiques de paris à l'automne 2000 24
ou au plus de ces mesures
et bien il y aura une activité du
chantier qui sera ralentie mais il y
aura une information sur les conditions
trafic qui sera renforcée pour faire en
sorte
et bien que ce chantier soit pas que du
que les convois d'athlètes et que le
public aussi puissent se rendre dans les
meilleures conditions aux sites
olympiques du secteur je pense aussi
d'elancourt de saint quentin en yvelines
oui parce qu'il y aura probablement est
évidemment même plus de circulation
pendant cette période du coup en tant
que responsable vous de la maîtrise
d'oeuvre michelle perell quel est le
rôle de la dirif de la direction des
routes d'île de france sur ce chantier
sur ce projet alors la dirif est maître
d'ouvragé de ce chantier
mais elle est accompagnée de partenaires
financiers que sont la région ile de
france
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le département
des yvelines et la ville de trappes
yvelines ses partenaires financiers sans
qui cette opération ne pourrait pas se
faire parce que concrètement la dirif
qui entretient exploiter modernise
mais 200 km d'autoroutes et de voies
rapides dans l'île de france
elles investissent et ses moyens limités
en modernisation du réseau pour
fluidifier et sécuriser la circulation
reprend là comme vous l'avez traité
représentés on est soit une opération
beaucoup plus ambitieuse qui vise à
rétablir de la continuité urbaine entre
les quartiers nord et suite de trappes
donc on est sur une opération d'ampleur
qui aujourd'hui estimé à 95 millions
d'euros
et donc on est en partenariat fort avec
les collectivités locales pour définir
et financer ce projet est géré de
l'apport financier que nous apporte ses
partenaires nous apporte également des
facilités foncière ils ont mis à
disposition par exemple des terrains qui
leur appartenait qui sont nécessaires
pour la réalisation des travaux
justement vous parliez finance ce projet
c'est un projet de longue date je les ai
rappelés 1999 qui a connu quelques
péripéties justement sur le financement
par l'état
une inversion des phases de travaux a dû
être fait pour que le gouvernement
n'engage pas une part financières trop
importantes
au lieu d'être la première étape cet
enfouissement de la n10 dont vous
parliez qui sera la dernière étape de ce
chantier est ce que l'on peut espérer
quand même voir cet indice enfouis 10 6
6 7 1 6 en travaux sont nécessaires donc
on a débuté cette année et elle a pour
objectif de terminer en 2026 dans le
guêpier
aujourd'hui alloués à l'opération donc
cet objectif sera tenu vous l'espérez
j'imagine c'est notre objectif
on est au tout démarrage des travaux les
aléas sont devant nous je serai bien
présomptueux dans est certain mais c'est
l'objectif et nous sommes soutenus par
les partenaires pour y arriver
eh bien merci michelle perell d'avoir
été avec nous sur ce plateau par
visioconférence merci dans l'actualité
également vendredi dernier les
conseillers départementaux 11 août est
le budget pour l'année 2000 21 1,6
milliard d'euros
si les recettes se maintiennent les
dépenses sont en augmentation pour
répondre aux conséquences de la crise
sanitaire les explications de nicolas
landry un budget adapté à l'accueil vide
pour le département en 2021 acteurs de
la politique sociale sur le territoire
le conseil départemental des yvelines va
notamment consacrer 183,6 millions
d'euros au versement du revenu de
solidarité active soit 15% de plus qu'en
2020 une obligation puisque le nombre de
bénéficiaires a augmenté de plus de 6%
dans les yvelines ce qui est lié à
l'augmentation du chômage longue durée
qui est lié à la fois à la crise
sanitaire et à une vieille crise
illinoise qui perdure qui est celle de
la crise industrielle
les yvelines qui sont d'un département
industriel ont vu
coût de ces industries sous la force de
la concurrence étrangère baisser
pavillon
avec un budget de 1,6 milliard d'euros
le département des yvelines peut compter
sur le maintien de ses recettes sans
augmentation d'impôts les compensations
et les dotations augmentation stable
donc c'est pour nous une douce ce nouvel
et nous avons une bonne tenue d'une
recette fiscales importantes que sont
les droits de mutation nous sommes assez
optimistes là dessus
le département poursuit aussi ses
investissements dans le soutien aux
communes la rénovation urbaine ou encore
dans la mobilité une enveloppe globale
de 467 millions d'euros tout en restant
attentif à la crise sanitaire
vous avez vu que les départements et
parce qu'il ya une gestion extrêmement
parcimonieuse extrêmement réfléchi et
plutôt en bonne situation financière
s'il faut je le redis d'utiliser cette
bonne santé financière pour financer des
opérations qu'on n'avait pas l'habitude
de financer dans le cadre de la pandémie
nous le saurons le département a par
exemple débloqué 15 millions d'euros
pour venir en aide aux commerçants
direction mantes-la-jolie où une petite
moitié des professeurs des collèges
chénier et sézanne ont fait grève hier
mardi 23 mars
objectif protester contre la destruction
de leur établissement et le regroupement
des élèves dans le futur collège
actuellement en construction en plein
coeur du val fourré 600 élèves au total
selon les syndicats de nombreuses
mutations de professeurs auraient été
demandé suite à ce projet une autre
information également cette fois ci à
saint germain en laye le collège debussy
est fermée jusqu'au 31 mars pour cause
de kovy de 19
cela fait suite à des tests salivaires
réalisé mardi 23 mars sur les élèves qui
auraient montré un taux élevé d'élèves
positif au qu'ovide 5% des 336 élèves
des cours en distanti elles seront donc
mis en place à partir de demain jeudi 25
mars et ce jusqu'au 31 mars inclus
et direction versailles à présent le
château a besoin des dents 2020
l'ancienne demeure des rois de france
n'a eu que deux millions de visiteurs
contre 8,2 millions l'année précédente
un manque à gagner de 70 millions
d'euros le département des yvelines a
donc prévu une enveloppe pour l'aider
1,15 million d'euros pardon sur les
trois prochaines années
reportage d'astrid bergère 15 millions
d'euros sur trois ans le département des
yvelines soutient le château de
versailles ouvert 192 jours seulement en
2020 il aujourd'hui bien vite de son
public et par conséquent en difficulté
financière dans les yvelines c'est
incomparablement le symbole de
l'élégance de la puissance de l'histoire
de la force de l'art et c'est en quelque
sorte un phare aussi les difficultés que
connaît aujourd'hui le château de
versailles méritait que alors que le
département est en train d'aider
l'ensemble des acteurs économiques en
particulier dans le secteur touristique
nous apparaît c'est normal d'aider aussi
le château de versailles une aide
nécessaire pour le château 75 % de ses
ressources propres viennent de la
billetterie un manque à gagner
considérable estimée à 70 millions
d'euros l'aide que nous apporte le
département des yvelines est fondamental
pour pouvoir continuer les travaux
d'entretien du château de versailles
pour pouvoir développer de projets que
nous aurions auquel nous aurions dû
renoncer si nous n'avions pas eu ce
soutien et comme j'ai coutume de le dire
ce que nous ne faisons pas aujourd'hui
c'est ce que nous perdons pour les
années à venir même si le château est
aujourd'hui fermée au public
les équipes doivent s'assurer qu'au
moment de la réouverture tout soit prêt
pour accueillir les visiteurs
aujourd'hui c'est un lieu qui est fait
pour accueillir le monde entier et on
doit maintenir
jour après jour le château de versailles
en état c'est sa force c'est sa force
pour le monde c'est de cette manière là
qu il rayonnera encore et toujours
devant tous nos amis étrangers mais
aussi pour la france
un soutien qui permettra entre autres de
participer à la rénovation des organes
de sécurité de l'opéra royal et à la
réfection des toitures et des façades de
plusieurs bâtiments une marque de
cosmétiques naturels et proches des
femmes c'est le but de l'entreprise li
na mais il y a moins de deux ans à saint
germain en laye elle souhaite maintenir
un contact fort avec sa clientèle
face à la crise sanitaire les précisions
de bixente mais rien senti stevan après
avoir travaillé dix ans pour de grandes
enseignes cosmétiques stéphanie gastal
d'un a décidé de créer sa propre marque
un projet né fin 2019 à saint germain en
laye d'où m'est venu effectivement l'ina
et c'est avant tout le lin donc je suis
originaire de normandie fille et
petite-fille de l'ine kurt liniculteurs
normand donc le lay m'est apparu comme
une évidence pour devenir le parfait
messager d'une cause de culture in
cosmetics à la fois locale et
coresponsable plus riches de bien fait
malgré les restrictions sociales
l'entreprise souhaite être proche des
femmes un produit n'est validé que
lorsqu'il est 100% approuvé par les
futures clientes
on leur fait tester également les soins
sous forme d'un questionnaire dont quel
test à domicile
les soumissions et elle suivait ce
question par question le questionnaire
et elles répondent en fonction de
différents critères la sensorialité
l'efficacité des produits approuvés par
les professionnels avec l'attribution de
récompenses aux officiels comme le prix
du meilleur produit naturel des
cosmétiques magot wars pour le soin de
jour savoir concrètement surtout et
à une époque on a besoin de savoir
quelle quelle est l'origine de nos
produits
j'ai été très rassurée par la provenance
et par la qualité des produits j'ai pu
faire les tests et puis un an et demi
que je les utilise et que j'en perçois
quotidiennement les bienfaits c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui la cosmétique peut
parfois faire peur il faut le dire avec
l'ina et je rassure les femmes de par la
composition en entre 98 et 100 %
d'ingrédients d'origine naturelle
jusqu'à 59 % d'ingrédients issus de
l'agriculture biologique
la marque est implantée dans une dizaine
de boutiques privilégiant le made in
france et la cosmétique naturelle et sur
des plates formes internet
en plus d'avoir son propre site et pour
refermer ce journal on le sait les
restaurateurs sont fermés depuis
plusieurs mois à cause de la crise
sanitaire face à cela le groupe feel
ogeris qui dirige 12 epad a décidé
d'ouvrir ses cuisines aux restaurateurs
exemple à la résidence mungo peau de
sartrouville par célia get on go parts
close depuis cinq mois pour ce
restaurant
mais à l'intérieur on s'affaire en
cuisine pour 40 couverts à midi des
clientes peu banal puisqu'il s'agit
aujourd'hui de résidents de l'ehpad mon
repos située à sartrouville 40 repas on
ne fait pas tous les jours depuis 1
depuis plus d'un an maintenant donc donc
évidemment nous ça nous ça nous rappelle
ça nous rappelle les temps avant que
vides ça me fait plaisir à moi bien sûr
de pouvoir travailler donc dans c'est un
plaisir pour tout le monde et j'espère
que ce sera un plaisir pour les
résidents également les restaurateurs
pendant cinq jours cette semaine
viennent assemblez les ingrédients et
dressés dans les assiettes
il assure même le service avec l'équipe
restauration les sourires se lisait sur
les visages des résidents
c'est bien
parce que dans le fond c'est un effort
de leur part et nous on en profite
oui c'est très bien comme ça on est tous
ensemble et puis je ça change un petit
peu les seuls plaisirs qu'il reste aux
résidents dans les ehpad ce sont les
activités et la nourriture
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a vraiment
voulu tabler sur cette partie
restauration
au menu aujourd'hui en entrée un velouté
de champignons avec noisettes torréfiées
huile de truffe ensuite steaks de thon
mi cuit à la plancha accompagné de
petits légumes aux boucles à la sauce
soja et enfin en dessert un ananas rôti
avec une mousse rock coco et un coulis
de manque
l'idée c'était de leur faire des petites
choses originales leur apporter des on
va dire des dégoûts un petit peu
différent je sais que j'ai prévu dans la
semaine certaines choses un petit peu
original des desserts avec une mousse à
l'estragon notamment voilà des petites
choses qui vont je pense dans la
titiller un peu leurs papilles en plus
des 34 résidents trois familles ont été
invités au repas
on compte en un petit repas là c'est une
superbe idée je trouve pour les
restaurateurs qui souffrent un peu plus
de cette période
comme quoi avec des bonnes idées des
fois on peut passer des bons moments
malgré les conditions difficiles
cette opération pourrait continuer
jusqu'à la réouverture des restaurants
avec un repas par semaine c'est déjà la
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
l'information revient demain à 18h en
direct dans le 7-8 journal présenté par
grégory canale et d'ici là je souhaite
une très bonne soirée
[Musique]